A seven-ship British fleet cuts into the pirate
bay of Nassau with imperial pomp, and fixes
its anchors into the seabed for the night.
Captain Woodes Rogers had triumphantly arrived
to impose the will of His Royal Majesty King
George of Great Britain and Ireland.
In the morning, he would tame this wretched
pirate haven ashore with sword and pistol,
and finally cleanse it from scum and villainy.
Night fell, and the crescent moon lights up the
deep ocean.
There is the gentle creak of bending wood,
as two ships push off from the island.
The nearer ship sails directly toward Rogers.
It heaves forward then bursts into flames.
The crew escape on cue, as shrapnel blisters
and spits in orange streaks over black waters.
Crackling inferno spreads to one British ship,
and the others scatter in the frenzy.
The fireship’s crew row to the second
vessel, and join their tenacious leader
- the ruthless pirate who deigns to defy
the King: Charles Vane.
Woodes Rogers watches him escape into the
smoldering, tropical night.
Vane understood perfectly well why Rogers
and the civilized world wanted to see him
hang: theft, torture, and murder were sins
to which he shamelessly admitted.
He reserved less sympathy for the scores of
pirates who had betrayed him - indeed, many
men he knew had stayed behind to welcome Woodes
Rogers into Nassau.
They had elected to accept this [b]so-called
King’s pardon.
But Vane had taken his chances.
He was no coward, and wouldn´t give up his
paradise that easily.
Nassau, which constituted the island of New
Providence in the Caribbean, had fallen out
of British hands some years ago.
Its winding farmlands and cobwebbed cannons
duly became the property of Charles Vane,
Blackbeard, Benjamin Hornigold, and thousands
of other pirates.[c]
Together, they had fashioned the island into
a Republic of Pirates, from which to plunder
this corner of the Atlantic, a liminal anarchy
between English, Spanish and French dominions.
But so great were their spoils, that those
royal dynasties of Europe fretted upon their
thrones and decried the unkempt outlaws who
so wantonly emptied their treasuries.
And so, Woodes Rogers had thus been tasked
with their extermination.
Despite Charles Vane’s fiery attack, Rogers
successfully made landfall the next morning.
He pardoned every pacified pirate ashore and
raised the Union Jack atop the dusty fort.
The hunt for the others who roamed these seas
was already underway.
Those who persisted in their thievery were
brought back to Nassau and walked to the gallows
in front of their former shipmates who had
accepted the pardon.
Woodes Rogers sat as governor of Nassau.
This seemed a momentous occasion - an age
of order was upon them.
If Charles Vane, Blackbeard, and the other
stragglers dared to resist, they would have
a front row seat to the end of their way of
life.
And indeed, this appeared to be the death
of a people who had long thrived like mold
on the dark underbellies of celebrated empires,
a people whose bloodstained legacy of freedom
and butchery and rebellion began eons before.
A proud history of piracy millenia long preceded
these men.
From empire toppling flotillas to singular
scoundrels and back again - this is their
story.
This is the story of the Pirates of the West.
Pirates didn't really have schools. They're training was mainly from their previous
lives as legitimate seafolk - taking their
previous sailing skills and using them to
their advantage.
These days its harder to do this so directly
- so services like Skillshare are hugely helpful
to train up for a new career, or progress
in your current one.
And its not just great for advancing your
career - skillshare is an online learning
community with thousands of inventive and
creative classes to choose from.
One great class I always come back to on Skillshare
is Creative Video Storytelling & Editing:
Making the Most of Stock Footage.
We use stock footage mixed with images in
videos here at Voices of the Past, and this
course has been great for exploring new ways
to create videos and tell stories.
It's just one of the many fantastic courses
they have on documentaries and film making,
and is just as useful as my previous recommendation
- "creating a modern cinematic documentary
film with soul", a staff pick and gem on the
platform.
Skillshare are the perfect option to make
the rest of 2022 a productive and creative
journey.
So, the first 1000 of my viewers to sign up
using the link in the description will get
a 1 month free trial of Skillshare so you
can start exploring your creativity today.
Thanks to Skillshare for supporting History
content on YouTube.
“All at once the lands were removed and
scattered in the fray.
No land could stand before their arms...
They were coming forward toward Egypt, while
the flame was prepared before them."
Life proceeded in Egypt as it had for thousands
of years.
High priests venerated monuments to the pharaohs
of old, while preaching cryptic wisdom of
the gods.
Camels carried travelers across searing dunes,
and crocodiles cooled their scales in the
flowing Nile.
Along its banks, common folk tended to the
fertile earth by day, and spent cold nights
cloistered in their mud-brick dwellings.
And above it all, on an ornate throne amidst
monuments to his own glory, sat a king beset
by tortured thoughts.
The 42-year-old Pharaoh Ramesses III was the
living incarnation of the avian god Horus,
said to will the very movement of the sun
and the moon.
But Ramesses had been fated to rule over a
bloody age.
It was 1175 BC, and the very idea of civilization
itself was in danger.
An existential threat stalked the Mediterranean:
powerful confederations of seafaring tribes
whose ranks were filled with masterful sailors,
savvy traders, and tenacious pirates.
Coastal cities were engulfed in flames.
“They desolated its people, and its land
was like that which has never come into being.”
[e]
Ramesses watched as the pirates ushered in
the Bronze Age collapse, seeing his rivals
fall to ruin.
Syria, the Levant, Cyprus, and Greece would
crumble.
The final hour of Egypt must have been close.
As these proto-pirates charted course to the
Nile, the Pharaoh called forth men from all
corners of the kingdom and furnished them
with shining lances, bows, and chariots.
“They were like lions roaring upon the mountain
tops.”[f]
The enemy flooded into the delta.
Their light vessels carried raiders clad in
all manner of armor, but undivided in their
determination to topple the old world.
A hail of arrows rained down.
The Egyptians charged with lances, squeezed
their opponents at a choke point, and ran
their ships aground.
Then, they ripped the pirates onto the sand
and hacked them to death.
[g]
“They were dragged in, enclosed, and prostrated
on the beach, killed, and made into heaps
from tail to head.”
Finally, a grisly red tide beat against the
sides of overturned ships.
Ramesses had prevailed, and the onslaught
of the piratical Sea Peoples was halted..
And so, it was this apocalyptic Battle of
the Delta that was memorialized on the outer
walls of Medinet Habu.
It may be the earliest depiction of a pirate
attack in existence.
It is likely that for as long as people have
elected to transport things of value over
the ocean, [h]there have existed people who
endeavored to steal those things.
But if piracy comprises robbery and violence
on the high seas and coastal areas, the Sea
Peoples showed that its practitioners need
not be mere ship-borne bandits.
On the contrary, the Sea Peoples traded, migrated,
and prudently navigated political allegiances.
Indeed, the pre-Classical Ancient Greeks understood
that piracy had once been considered an entirely
legitimate source of financial sustenance.
The jagged edges of the Mediterranean were
unsuitable for large-scale agriculture, but
passing trade ships hugged the coastlines.
Like tempting sirens, they beckoned sailors
and fishermen toward a treacherous life of
piracy.
“[Barbarians] were tempted to turn pirates,
under the conduct of their most powerful men;
the motives being to serve their own greed
and to support the needy.
They would fall upon a town unprotected by
walls, and consisting of a mere collection
of villages, and would plunder it; indeed,
this came to be the main source of their livelihood,
no disgrace being yet attached to such an
achievement, but even some glory.”[i]
While small bands of piratical opportunists
proved an inevitable reality of the ancient
world, many of the most fervent practitioners
of piracy were more legitimate states or confederacies.
Entire peoples like the Illyrians and Phoenecians
participated in large scale trading and cultural
exchange, in addition to fairly indiscriminate
piracy.
But pirates nevertheless thrived on instability.
In a pattern that would characterize piracy
for millennia to come, places that had fallen
into ruin due to war or neglect became the
most attractive pirate dens— the cracked
vestiges of the Minoan civilization on Crete
and islands scarred by Peloponnesian conflict
became bases for pirates to organize raids
on ships and coasts, taking goods and slaves
with them.
But the winds of empire threatened piracy.
As Alexander toppled cities and the star of
Rome enveloped Greece, pirate hegemony waned.
Rome used accusations of piracy as a justification
for conquest.
Naturally, such accusations were fraught with
inconsistency and hypocrisy.
[j]Ancient pirates conquered ill-guarded land,
pillaged ships and coastlines, and conducted
slave raids in a manner not dissimilar from
contemporary empires.
Defining which kinds of ship-borne robbery
fell outside of the law would continue to
be a matter of perspective
and convenience.
The Northern Greek Aetolian League, which
had practiced large-scale piracy against its
enemies, was defeated by the Roman Republic
in 192 BC.
But the Romans had simply pushed the issue
beyond their gaze.
The Aetolian pirates fled and set up operations
in the nook of Asia Minor, where they garnered
the support of local kings too weak to drive
them out.
Based in the dilapidated towns of Cilicia,
the most fearsome pirate community the ancient
world had ever seen now swarmed the Mediterranean.
In their voracious slave-raiding, these Cilician
pirates made friends in powerful places.
The hostage refused to stay quiet.
In truth, his captors found him amusing.
Drunken cackling of sunburnt pirates echoed
along the coast as they watched him perform
poems and speeches with boyish pluck, the
warm, turquoise borders of the Eastern Mediterranean
his tranquil prison.[l]
The confused Cilicians listened intently to
the brash young Roman.
Their hostage had suggested they raise the
ransom for his freedom to more accurately
reflect his status, and the Cilicians had
complied.
His countrymen may have controlled the Western
Mediterranean, but the eastern half remained
pirate territory.
The Cilicians attacked with little regard
for the allegiances of their victims.
The powerful landowners and senators of Rome
nevertheless tolerated them, as the profitability
of their sweeping plantations depended on
a stable relationship with the pirates.
For peacetime in the Republic made for bad
business.
Without conquered peoples to be sold in Roman
markets, Roman landowners turned to the Cilician
pirates, who eagerly sold them people they
had captured in slave raids.
While Rome stood as a shining bastion of civilization,
the pirate underworld was her concealed accomplice.
If pirates were to roam the seas, empires
would continue to find ways to use their presence
to their advantage.
But Cilician looting of Roman shipping also
created fervent enemies in Rome, and Rome
began to enact antipiracy laws.
The derision with which the Roman hostage
treated his captors may have reflected this
change in attitudes.
When he wished to sleep, the Roman would interrupt
the late-night revelry of the pirates and
tell them to stop talking.
In passing, he muttered teasing threats to
have his captors executed.
After a month, the ransom came, and the young
captive, named Julius Caesar, sailed off.
The pirates decided to linger on the coast
a little while longer, bobbing at anchor and
basking in their earnings.
But their celebrations were soon cut short.
A fleet appeared on the horizon.
Caesar had returned.
He had the pirates thrown in prison and reclaimed
the ransom money.
“He went to Pergamon, took the pirates out
of prison and crucified the lot of them, just
as he had often told them he would do when
he was on the island and they imagined that
he was joking.”
But Cilician pirates continued to undermine
the stability of the Roman Republic.
Indeed when Spartacus launched a slave revolt
two years later, in 73 BC, the Cilicians supported
his efforts.
Though when Spartacus met with the pirates
and paid them to transport 2,000 of his rebels
to Sicily, the Cilicians took the gifts and
sailed off without them.
They then burned the Roman port of Ostia and
kidnapped two Roman senators.
Now, common Romans felt the material shock
on grain supplies and the economy.
They looked to the rising General Pompey to
confront the issue, and he gathered support
for a costly mission: the complete annihilation
of the Cilician pirates.
The Senate passed the “Gabinian Law.”
“The law gave him dominion over the sea
this side of the pillars of Hercules, over
all the mainland to the distance of four hundred
furlongs from the sea.
These limits included almost all places in
the Roman world, and the greatest nations
and most powerful kings were comprised within
them.
Besides this, he was empowered to... take
from the public treasuries and the tax-collectors
as much money as he wished, and to have two
hundred ships, with full power over the number
and levying of soldiers and oarsmen.”
With over a hundred thousand troops at his
disposal, Pompey sent forth his army to hound
the pirates at every corner.
They blockaded and demolished pirate lairs
and drove many of the stragglers back to Cilicia.
Roman ships followed them and formed impenetrable
rows of blockades, forcing the pirates onto
land.
From there, the Roman troops slaughtered the
pirates with mechanical efficiency.
Upon their surrender, Pompey had Cilician
leaders killed.
The others, he showed mercy.
“Reflecting, therefore, that by nature man
neither is nor becomes a wild or an unsocial
creature, but is transformed by the unnatural
practice of vice...he determined to transfer
the men from the sea to land, and let them
have a taste of gentle life by being accustomed
to dwell in cities and to till the ground”
Pompey had tamed the seas.
In all, he had razed 120 pirate bases, destroyed
500 ships, and killed 10,000 pirates.
A Pax Romana washed over the Mediterranean;
and in the coming centuries, friends of Rome
were free to sail without serious danger.
Piracy, it seemed, had been defeated once
and for all.
So long as the Eternal City of Rome stood,
the western pirate would remain extinct.
A shout echoed through the cold corridors
of a castle.
Pirate brethren scrambled to their posts,
and peered beyond the walls.
Cutting across soft mounds of snow, was a
line of clattering iron and black crosses.
The pirates readied their feeble defenses,
as the Teutonic Knights marched with gleaming
swords and crossbows.
The soldiers of Christ had come to carry out
a royal bounty, a quest to slaughter the doomed
pirates in their fortress and finally end
medieval piracy - a bloody era of seaborne
banditry inaugurated centuries earlier, by
heathens.
“...[T]he pagans from the northern regions
came with a naval force to Britain like stinging
hornets and spread on all sides like fearful
wolves, robbed, tore and slaughtered not only
beasts of burden, sheep and oxen, but even
priests and deacons, and companies of monks
and nuns.
And they came to the church of Lindisfarne,
laid everything waste with grievous plundering,
trampled the holy places with polluted steps,
dug up the altars and seized all the treasures
of the holy church.
They killed some of the brothers, took some
away with them in fetters, many they drove
out, naked and loaded with insults, some they
drowned in the sea..."
Through beards doused in frothy mead, men
of the north orchestrated the downfall of
far-off kingdoms.
In their mead halls, they gathered before
a crackling hearth and wooden throne in a
quest for untold riches and immortal glory
in Valhalla.
The fractured nations of northern Europe had
left shining treasures and exotic goods on
their shores, exposed and ready to be plundered.
Viking piracy did not constitute robbery on
the high seas, but instead took the form of
lightning coastal raids.
Ship-borne attacks on wherever they saw wealth
earned them precious artefacts and innumerable
slaves.
Over the centuries, disjointed raids on small
villages and monasteries grew to fully fledged
excursions upon cities and vast territories.
These Vikings, or raiders, terrorized the
distant corners of Europe - the audacious
Hasting and Bjorn Ironside ventured as far
as Islamic Spain, sowing chaos on the sunkissed
Guadallquvir river in Seville.
They went on to burn and pillage Southern
France and Italy, terrorizing Mediterranean
waters from which the watchful eye of Rome
had retreated long ago.
For the stability of the Western Roman Empire
had long since collapsed.
Though the Byzantine Empire took up the Roman
mantle in the east, they held no real sway
in Rome´s heartland.
And soon, Muslim factions had gained footholds
in North Africa, Iberia, and the Middle East.
Then came the Crusades, and the Byzantine
Empire too fractured into a series of rump
states, ceasing to exist.
In the ruins of this second empire, pirates
returned.
The very sailors who had once filled the ranks
of the Byzantine navy set up hideouts at its
crumbling corners, and began to ambush merchant
ships.
Rumblings from the East then foretold a new
wave of bloodshed— an unstoppable horde
of steppe warriors rode west under the banner
of Genghis Khan.
With pirates infesting the coasts and Mongols
at the gates, a claimant to the defunct Byzantine
throne emerged: Michael VIII retook Constantinople
and resurrected an empire which had laid dormant
for six decades.
But the return of Byzantine authority did
not guarantee stability.
Unable to muster a true national navy, he
decided to weaponize Mediterranean pirates
for Byzantine ends.
He called pirate leaders from their remote
hideouts, and turned them into his privateers—
sailors who could use their own ships to plunder
under Byzantine authority.
Legitimate piracy was born.[m]
This would set a precedent for the centuries
to come.
Pirates were above all shapeshifters— opportunists
disposed to true piracy at times, and the
legal protection of privateering at others.
Men who had for years ruled as pirates, now
justified their pillaging and violence against
Italian trade under the banner of the Byzantine
Empire.
For a cash-strapped kingdom, seaborne mercenaries
presented a viable alternative to a legitimate
navy, and Northern Europe would soon realize
this.
The deposed Swedish King Albert sat in a dungeon,
in desperate need of aid.
Scattered beyond his city of Stockholm were
forested specks of land, sat in dark and briny
waters.
Glacial currents shimmered with herring, and
bent under the strain of hostile ships that
infested the harbor.
This was a suffocating blockade: a gift from
the new Swedish monarch, Margaret of Denmark.
At roughly forty years of age, the shrewd
Queen Margaret claimed rulership over all
of Scandinavia.
The dark-haired queen, known to be beautiful
and intimidating in equal measure, was hellbent
on uniting the region at all costs.
Thus, as Stockholm remained loyal to King
Albert, Margaret decided to starve the city.
No ordinary sailor could penetrate the swarm.
The allies of King Albert turned instead to
professionals.
Handsomely-paid German mercenaries were sent
to slip through the blockade and run supplies
into Stockholm.
These armed men soon acted as privateers,
wreaking havoc on the merchant vessels of
Margaret and her allies.
Together, they formed a guild called the Victual
Brothers.
In need of a safe base of operations, the
Victual Brothers took the town Visby on the
island of Gotland, one of Margaret’s Swedish
territories.
And In 1394, the unabashed pirates became
the de facto rulers of Gotland.
The seas were chaos.
The Victual Brothers assailed so many passing
ships that trade became impossible.
Economies floundered.
The fishing industry was halted and food supplies
dwindled.
In exasperated meetings, Margaret called for
aid.
Finally, it was an old order of knights that
took up the Queen’s quest.
Based in Prussia, the Crusaders of the Teutonic
Order came forward, with troops prepared with
broad swords and exquisite shining armor.
They boasted menacing visored helmets and
shields bearing black crosses.
The knights desired to control Gotland; Queen
Margaret promised to grant their wish if they
could clear the island of the pirates.
And in the winter of 1397-1398, the Victual
Brothers docked their ships.
Almost all came ashore to weather the Scandinavian
cold on Gotland.
The Knights and their Prussian troops sailed
out in secret to meet them.
84 ships and 4,000 men were to attack under
the leadership of Grandmaster Konrad von Jungingen.
They clambered ashore and met the pirates
in the snow.
As negotiations for peace took place, the
Knights and their Prussian army marched to
every corner of the island.
They found the pirates tucked away in castles
and forts; they laid siege to their defenses,
and hacked to death and filled with arrows
the Victual Brothers they found.
The knights finally demolished the city of
Visby and conquered the island.
They afforded pirates three days to leave
the island.
Those who lingered were captured and killed.
Leaders like Klaus Störtebeker continued
pirating for years, but even he was caught,
brought in, and executed with his crew.
If European waters had truly fallen into the
hands of powerful kings and queens like Margaret,
then piracy would need to move beyond their
gaze.
Perhaps there was money to be made further
afield.
And indeed, in a century’s time, Europeans
would make dangerous forays into an uncharted
ocean.
Explorers and conquistadors stumbled upon
a new hemisphere of jungles, tropical islands,
and vast civilizations - brimming with wealth.
Pirates, and politically useful privateers,
would soon take notice.
Eyes of a scowling Aztec god set into priceless
gold.
Chests of clattering gems, lumps of silver,
and sacred headdresses.
A live jaguar baring its teeth with every
sway of the ship.
And a Spanish sailor trying his best not to
make eye contact.
Stolen souvenirs from the New World— courtesy
of Hernan Cortes.
Cortes and his ironclad conquistadors had
waded through the Mexican jungle, orchestrating
a large indigenous resistance against Aztec
rule.
They had then used the chaos to wrest control
of the region and bleed the crumbling empire
of Montezuma of its abundant wealth.
Now, the trio of Spanish ships creaked home,
heavy with treasure.
The sailors were to guard the secret cargo
at all costs.
Their gaze swept over the horizon as they
awaited a pair of armed vessels to escort
them on the last leg of their journey.
But instead, one by one, strange shapes rose
above the curve of the Atlantic.
Five mysterious boats swarmed after the Spanish
trio.
The treasure-laden ships groaned and clanked
as the Spaniards wheeled hard in the opposite
direction.
The attackers dogged them for hours, until
at last, they apprehended two of them.
With sharpened blades and feathered flamboyance,
Captain Jean Fleury and his French crew demanded
they surrender, lest they come aboard by force,
and duly butcher every Spaniard they saw.
The exhausted Spaniards surrendered without
fanfare, and the Frenchmen came aboard to
haul away the treasure, chest by chest.
In the eyes of France, Jean Fleury was not
a criminal, but a hero - for he possessed
a document called a letter of marque.
These were licenses issued during war, which
offered sailors the legal permission of their
home country to hunt, attack, and capture
non-combat vessels of rival nations.
Men whoß might have otherwise been hunted
as pirates, could function as private agents
of the state, or privateers, allowed to declare
and keep most of the loot they plundered.
Privateers like Fleury were the product of
a changing Europe, whose fractured kingdoms
had begun to crystallize into potent empires.
The Kingdom of France had risen in competition
with the other established monarchies of Spain,
Portugal, and the Holy Roman Empire.
Blocked in the east by the Muslim Ottoman
Empire, these warring Western European dynasties
began seeking alternative routes to the lucrative
East Indies.
Columbus had made landfall on American soil
in 1492, and now conquistadors sailed about
the Americas in search of glory, land, and
treasure.
But if Spain had truly landed in a new world,
her burgeoning empire would become the natural
target of her rivals.
Even after his capture, as Jean Fleury swung
from the gallows, the Frenchman had set something
in motion.
His privateering had revealed to the world
what riches the Spanish had uncovered in their
grisly New World conquests, and placed a target
on their treasure-laden vessels.
In 1536, the French attacked Havana and other
Spanish New World ports.
The following year, French privateers cut
in half the Spanish income from the New World.
Spain recognized its treasure ships were in
the most dire need of protection, so the Crown
developed the flota system.
No longer would treasure ships travel exposed
across the Atlantic.
Well-armed convoys were rallied to escort
them.
Seaside forts with armored soldiers and cannons
would also be raised around key ports.
And in the wake of peace between Spain and
France in 1559 French letters of marque dried
up and legitimate French privateers disappeared
from the Spanish Main.
But that was far from the end.
For across the channel, Elizabeth I took up
their mantle - The English Queen, a staunch
Protestant, viewed Spain as a bitter political
and religious rival.
Armed with her own letters of marque, she
let loose her Sea Dogs.
Camped at the edge of a chirping jungle stood
a goateed adventurer - an intrepid Englishman
with vengeance in his heart.
For this secret mission, Francis Drake had
assembled a band of loot-hungry individuals—
English privateers like himself, the French
buccaneer Le Tetsu, and a network of savvy
runaway slaves.
Drake had tracked the Spanish treasure shipments
all the way here, to the Isthmus of Panama.
In the morning, mule loads would secretly
cart South American treasures to the city
of Nombre de Dios, before they were shipped
back to Spain.
The son of a farmer, Drake desired most of
all riches and glory - The Spanish had thwarted
his commercial endeavors in the New World
- they were a natural target.
Bells rang out.
The caravan approached.
200 mules labored forward, laden with 30 tons
of New World treasure.
Dozens of Spanish soldiers marched alongside
them.
Drake met them head on.
He recounted,
“...in the end, these soldiers thought it
the best way to leave their mules with us,
and to seek for more help abroad...In which
meantime we took some pain to ease some of
the mules which were heaviest loaden of their
carriage.
And because we ourselves were somewhat weary,
we were contented with a few bars and quoits
of gold, as we could well carry: burying about
fifteen tons of silver…”
Spanish reinforcements would arrive any minute.
With glowing gold in their arms, Dake and
his men marched for miles under damp vines
and dangling vipers.
Drake and his crew neared the end of the mountainous
jungle.
At last, they stumbled onto the beach where
they had left their ships, only to find that
they had disappeared.
Spanish vessels loomed along the coastline
in their place.
The pirates could see their capture and death
were imminent.
Drake acted quickly; he ordered the men to
bury their gold and make a raft from the trees.
They drifted ten miles down the coast until
they reached his flagship, and safety.
Drake later returned to recover the gold,
took a captain’s portion for himself, and
divided the rest amongst the French and English.
Francis Drake’s first foray into the world
of privateering would enable an illustrious
career.
He returned to England a celebrity of sorts,
and forged a close relationship with the Queen,
who affectionately referred to him as “my
pirate.”, sending him on various unofficial
missions to plunder the ships of her Spanish
rivals.
In his elegant vessel, the Golden Hind, Drake
circumnavigated the planet, harassing and
plundering Spanish ports and ships along the
way.
Driven more by opportunity than any lofty
ideals, Drake could just as easily plunder
the Spanish Main shoulder-to-shoulder with
runaway slaves, as he could sell captured
Africans into slavery.
And after warding off the Spanish Armada’s
attack on England, Drake became something
of a national hero.
Of course, self-interest could underlie his
actions at any time.
In 1588, when tasked with shadowing the invading
Spanish armada, he defied orders and instead
hunted after a treasure-filled ship.
Since the Crown took its cut of all privateer
plunder, Drake hid half of this stolen gold
before returning to London, and then bought
himself a mansion.
This was the unique duality of privateering,
where greed and self-interest could shakily
coexist with national service.
French, English, and Dutch privateers readily
hoisted their sails for the promise of untold
wealth, and were hailed as rugged heroes in
their home countries.
An account of Drake’s exploits, cosigned
by the man himself, was titled: Sir Francis
Drake Revived: Calling Upon This Dull or Effeminate
Age, to Follow His Noble Steps for Gold and
Silver.
Though peace between Spain and England would
come, and the era of unchecked privateering
would pass, that same century saw the terrifying
rise of a pirate power farther east.
Perched on the northern edge of Africa, Muslim
pirates attacked the very heart of the Christian
empires that laid claim to the Americas.
Conquistadors left American soil and returned
to the Mediterranean in anxious haste.
A storm was brewing.
It was said that until the late nineteenth
century, a mountain of skulls stood on the
Tunisian island of Djerba.
Passersby gazed upon a yellowed tower of human
bone— sunken faces with mouths agape.
The heads had been harvested from Spanish
sailors three centuries prior.
They were the victims of a man called Dragut.
The newest slave brought with him notoriety.
Rumors about him spread throughout the stinking
Italian ship: tales of his escapades, when
black stacks of smoke had bloomed along the
Italian coast and his pointed ships carried
away goods and people.
They said he was a great Barbary pirate, by
the name of Dragut.
Whispers spread that he had even trained under
the famed corsair Hayreddin Barbarossa—
together felling Italian fortresses and capturing
precious merchant ships from distant infidels.
The rumours were true.
Like all Barbary corsairs, Dragut had acted
as a pirate or privateer, ravaging Christian
coastlines and exchanging a cut of the loot
for safety and status in the Islamic coastal
polities of North Africa, or, the so-called
Barbary States.
The region offered little in the way of natural
resources, so rulers had developed states
reliant on mass piracy.
Though functionally quite independent, the
Barbary States fell under the nominal control
of the mighty Ottoman Empire, which spanned
from Greece to Africa.
Barbary privateers could be called upon by
the Ottomans in times of war, and Dragut’s
privateering had earned him prestige among
Ottoman leadership—most Barbary rulers were,
in fact, corsairs themselves.
But today, Dragut possessed neither power
nor pride.
He had been captured by Italians after a bloody
raid and condemned to the oar: a backbreaking
life aboard an Italian vessel.
In the sweltering belly of the ship, Dragut
heaved, and pushed and pulled the oars day
after day.
His wiry muscles ached and his throat grew
parched.
And so, the once notorious pirate festered
in obscurity.
The man who had stolen and kidnapped countless
goods and people, now appeared destined to
die a slave.
Stripped of Dragut’s prowess, the Barbary
pirates looked vulnerable.
At this time, Charles V reigned over much
of Europe, and with the blessing of the Pope,
he called upon the nations of Christendom
to sail out against the Ottoman-backed Barbary
pirates.
To challenge the Ottomans was a dangerous
proposition.
It was, after all, Ottoman overland hegemony
that had initially compelled Europeans like
Columbus and Vasco da Gama to seek alternative
trade routes to Asia.
Nobody appreciated that fact more than one
aging conqueror who had joined the fleet.
Hernan Cortes peered out from a weather-beaten
face, wreathed by a beard that had grown gray.
The man derided as a cruel tyrant by many
in Central America, had returned to the seas
of the Old World to challenge the Barbary
corsairs and, perhaps, to reclaim some of
the honor and glory to which he felt so entitled.
The fleet set out in 1541, to take back the
Mediterranean under the command of the Genoese
statesman Andrea Doria.
But terrible storms beset the expedition and
tossed about the invading ships.
Cortes nearly drowned, Doria lost nearly 150
vessels.
When at last the remaining soldiers made landfall,
the locals massacred some, and sold so many
of the survivors into slavery
it was said the price of a Christian head
became equal to that of an onion.
In the wake of the failed attack, the Ottomans
enjoyed unprecedented control over the Mediterranean.
Under the cover of drooping tents, the markets
of the Barbary coast every day bustled with
the fruitful exchange of goods and people—stolen
from passing ships or the coasts of West Africa
and Europe.
But even in the wake of victory, the Barbary
States felt the absence of Dragut.
He still sat behind rusty bars in Genoa.
The Ottomans eventually surrounded the city
and threatened to lay siege to it, unless
Dragut was set free.
The wary Genoese refused.
The Ottomans paid a fortune in ransom money.
Although years in slavery had drained Dragut,
freedom proved invigorating.
He returned to the seas with ferocity.
In 1546, the Ottoman Sultan named him the
commander of the Ottoman fleet and Bey of
Algiers.
As the de facto leader of the Barbary corsairs,
Dragut wrested control of Tripoli from the
Knights of St. John and expelled European
incursions on the Barbary coast.
And so, In 1560, Andrea Doria planned to destroy
his rival again.
His ships sailed out to swarm Dragut, but
in the Battle of Djerba, Dragut decimated
their fleet.
Dragut and corsairs pulled the Spanish from
their ships, removed their heads, and stacked
their skulls into a pyramid.
Dragut had overseen the apex of Ottoman control
in the Mediterranean.
He died in battle a few years later.
The Barbary States he left behind were destined
to change.
Burgeoning English and Dutch naval powers
pushed the Barbary corsairs into a tenuous
peace in the 17th century.
The Barbary States were forced to move away
from large scale attacks on shipping in the
Mediterranean, and shifted their focus instead
to slavery.
And so now we return to the Atlantic.
The quiet seaside village of Baltimore sat
where the rocky coast meets verdant Irish
hills.
Squinting from the shore, villagers noticed
strange sails one day in 1631.
Armed Barbary pirates disembarked.
Baltimore was left a ghost town— little
more than shattered windows and the scattered
belongings of missing people.
Every man, woman, and child who hadn’t managed
to flee was brought in chains to the Barbary
coast.
A priest watched their arrival in the slave
market, “It was a piteous sight to see them
exposed for sale at Algiers, for when they
parted the wife from the husband, and the
father from the child; then, say I, they sell
the husband here, and the wife there, tearing
from her arms the daughter whom she cannot
hope to see ever again.”
Enslaved men were likely to spend their years
as galley slaves, while women and children
were liable to be forced into concubinage.
And as Europeans would soon come to appreciate,
slave trading paid handsomely.
Crossing the Atlantic, the Spanish enslaved
indigenous people to extract wealth from American
soil.
This new land and wealth soon attracted rival
colonial powers.
While the Spanish claimed Central and most
of South America, and Portugal claimed Brazil,
the English, Dutch, and French began to encroach
and establish colonies in North America.
If the Old World’s age of mass privateering
had seen its heyday under Dragut, the New
World’s golden age of privateering had just
begun.
L’olonnais would squeeze out the eyes, burn
the flesh, and remove the tongues of those
who refused to tell him what he wanted to
hear.
Now, L'olonnais demanded that the captured
Spaniard tell him the truth: whether or not
he knew a safe, unguarded path to the city
of San Pedro.
The Spaniard undoubtedly sensed that the Frenchman
planned to raid the city and torture from
its civilians every ounce of wealth they possessed.
The Spaniard told L'olonnais that he knew
of no such way to San Pedro.
The story continues:
“Having asked them all, and finding they
could show him no other way, Lolonois grew
outrageously passionate; so that he drew his
cutlass, and with it cut open the breast of
one of those poor Spaniards, and pulling out
his heart began to bite and gnaw it with his
teeth, like a ravenous wolf, saying to the
rest, "I will serve you all alike, if you
show me not another way."
Hereupon, those miserable wretches promised
to show him another way.”
It was cold cruelty that had lifted L'olonnais
from the misery of indentured servitude to
the heights of pirate leadership.
He had captured treasure ships and pillaged
towns, all the while attracting followers
to his cause.
Like other so-called buccaneers, he operated
out of the neglected island of Tortuga.
Over the years, his fleet of one ramshackle
ship had swelled to eight.
But now, the Spanish looked prepared.
When he reached San Pedro, they repelled his
attack.
Fortune continued to turn against him.
He sailed along the Central American coast,
and his ship ran aground.
“To this effect he determined to go on to
the coasts of Carthagena; but God Almighty,
the time of His Divine justice being now come,
had appointed the Indians of Darien to be
the instruments and executioners thereof...
Hither Lolonois came (brought by his evil
conscience that cried for punishment), thinking
to act his cruelties; but the Indians within
a few days after his arrival took him prisoner,
and tore him in pieces alive, throwing his
body limb by limb into the fire, and his ashes
into the air, that no trace or memory might
remain of such an infamous, inhuman creature.”
Contemporaries of L'olonnais judged him a
wicked man.
But his rise had been made possible by the
unique conditions brought about by rivalries
among overstretched empires, and nurtured
in the backwater regions to which Spain tenuously
laid claim.
L'olonnais was part of a growing class of
pirate, known in this age as buccaneers...
Buccaneers had always existed in defiance
of the Spanish Crown, but they hadn’t always
been pirates.
They had gotten their start as poor settlers
who ventured into the overgrown north end
of Spanish Hispaniola to rustle feral cattle
and pigs.
The forest-dwellers sold this meat to English,
Dutch, and French merchants in exchange for
weapons, ammunition, and rum.
Since Hispaniola's native Taino people had
traditionally cooked meat on wooden frames
called buccan, the French and English took
to calling these meat smugglers boucaniers
or buccaneers.
The Spanish, meanwhile, referred to these
English, Dutch and French merchants as “interlopers,”.
To safeguard their monopoly and ward them
off, they drove the buccaneers from Hispaniola
and decimated the animals they hunted.
In doing so, the Spanish inadvertently created
a pirate haven.
The island of Tortuga: a tropical paradise
where, from the 1630s onward, disaffected
smugglers could carouse with French, English,
and Dutch interlopers and build a Caribbean
black market.
Soon, these men of Tortuga turned to piracy.
The buccaneers began to sail out on small
boats in the dead of night to ambush Spanish
trade ships.
Around this time, the French and Dutch arose
as commercial and naval rivals to the Spanish
in the 30 Years’ War, which pitted the Catholic
Habsburg rulers of Spain and Austria against
the Dutch Republic and the rival Bourbon house
of France.
Spain’s grasp on the New World was loosening.
The English established colonies across the
North American East coast; and the French
began to venture from Canada to Louisiana.
But despite a dizzying succession of 17th-century
wars between European powers, the politics
in Caribbean waters were refreshingly simple.
The Spanish were the enemy.
Regardless of the goings on in Europe, English,
Dutch, and French governors in the West Indies
had made their choice.
Colonial authorities weaponized the buccaneers
of Tortuga with letters of marque, and let
them loose on the Spanish.
The buccaneers of Tortuga smelled blood in
the water.
They raided the cities along the Spanish Main
and Spain’s merchant ships.
Africans, escaped slaves, and outlaws also
joined their ranks.
In spite of the sadism practiced by buccaneers
like L’olonnais, these self-titled “Brethren
of the Coast” generally boasted a commonwealth
spirit, whereby decisions were made collectively,
resources were pooled together, and loot was
divided according to well-understood parameters.
Like the English Sea Dogs of Francis Drake’s
time or the Barbary pirates, buccaneers toed
the line between roguish outlaws and agents
of the state.
When war reached Tortuga, it was English colonial
authorities who graciously provided a new
buccaneer haven.
England had taken Jamaica in 1655, and its
city of Port Royal now provided implicit support
for these anti-Spanish privateers.
Under the regal banner of England, the buccaneers
arrived in ships stocked with plundered rum,
slaves, cloth, and cash crops.
The ensuing trade facilitated the scandalous
metamorphosis of Port Royal into the so-called
“Sodom of the New World.”
Here, a buccaneer could squander his Spanish
loot, cheer and brawl in a muggy tavern, or
unwind on the warped mattress of a busy brothel.
When one clergyman retired from his attempts
to preach to the inhabitants of Port Royal,
he remarked, “the majority of its population
consists of pirates, cutthroats, whores and
some of the vilest persons in the whole of
the world.”
Port Royal became a blackmarket boomtown that
rivaled the upright prosperity of England’s
Puritan Boston.
Tortuga, meanwhile, continued to serve as
a neutral port for buccaneers.
It was into this world of opportunity that
Henry Morgan sailed in the early 1660s.
The sailor, in his early thirties, had cut
his teeth as a Welsh privateer sacking Spanish
cities.
Steady, deep-set brown eyes betrayed a cunning
self-assuredness.
He had trained under powerful buccaneers,
but the time had come to build his own legacy.
Anchoring in Port Royal, he flaunted his English
letter of marque.
It authorized attacks on Spanish shipping,
and unsavory sailors wallowing in the town’s
taverns were keen to take advantage.
12 ships and 500 English and Frenchmen sailed
out under Morgan’s command.
In a matter of days, Morgan had become the
de facto king of the buccaneers.
The invasion fleet dropped anchor on the Haitian
coast.
In truth, letters of marque only licensed
the seizure of enemy vessels on the high seas
- but Morgan knew his countrymen in Port Royal
were likely to turn a blind eye to any profitable
misstep he might make.
From the Haitian beach, Morgan rallied the
buccaneers and stormed the city of Puerto
del Principe.
They killed hundreds of Spanish defenders
and pillaged for three days, but their earnings
were insufficient.
The buccaneers moaned and cursed - until Morgan
offered up an idea: they would move on to
the Panamanian coast and attack the city of
Portobelo.
Stocked full of shimmering Spanish treasure,
but crawling with well-trained militiamen,
Portobelo was a dangerous prize.
The French, who had followed Morgan thus far,
balked at the idea and sailed off.
Captain Morgan remarked, "If our number is
small, our hearts are great; and the fewer
persons we are, the more union and better
shares we shall have in the spoil."
The unwavering Morgan roused the remaining
crew and guided his fleet quietly through
the Bocas del Toro.
They transferred into smaller vessels when
they reached the coast.
The weary pirates staggered onto the beach
and marched toward Portobelo.
At daybreak, they charged.
The morning silence was split by musket fire.
Morgan and his men advanced in a haze of blackpowder.
Women screamed and children fled.
The buccaneers fired at every living thing
in sight.
Morgan overran the city, but the precious
citadel of Fort Santiago still loomed in the
distance.
The Spanish militia atop its walls rained
down stones and explosive pots on all who
neared the fort.
Morgan pulled back and adjusted his strategy.
He readied siege ladders and corralled the
city’s nuns and friars, forcing them to
march forth in a human shield.
“Thus the ladders...were put into the hands
of religious persons of both sexes, and these
were forced, at the head of the companies,
to raise and apply them to the walls…”
“Thus many of the religious men and nuns
were killed before they could fix the ladders;
which at last being done, though with great
loss of the said religious people, the pirates
mounted them in great numbers...being now
at the top of the walls, they kindled and
cast in among the Spaniards.“
They buccaneers killed the governor in front
of his own wife and daughter, and wounded
or killed every other Spaniard therein.
With Portobelo hostage, Henry Morgan sensed
an opportunity.
He sent a letter to the governor of Panama:
“Tomorrow we plan to burn this city to the
ground and then set sail with all the guns
and munitions from the castles.
With us we will take all our prisoners….and
we will show them the same kindness that the
English prisoners have received in this place.”
Morgan added that he would spare the city
of this fate if the governor promptly paid
him 350,000 pieces-of-eight.
From their conquered forts, Morgan’s buccaneers
repulsed the Panamanian counterattack, negotiated
a ransom for 100,000 pieces-of-eight, and
sailed off.
However news of changing diplomatic tides
met them on the docks, and spoiled their homecoming.
It appeared the age of the buccaneer was coming
to a close.
England had adopted friendlier relations with
Spain and the Crown now rebuked this wave
of piracy.
Henry Morgan was forced to retire.
But not for long.
Global communication in those days was fraught
with delay.
Local Spanish authorities, ignorant of the
new truce, sent out privateers to exact revenge
on the English for the Portobelo raid.
Their hostility, in turn, provided Morgan
with an opportunity to return to the seas
and fulfill an earlier promise: to sack the
most prized metropolis in the Americas: Panama
City.
In early 1671, Morgan readied the buccaneers
for his greatest plan yet.
They overran the city, scavenged all the wealth
they could find, brutalized the inhabitants,
and burned it to the ground.
Morgan was arrested for piracy and transported
to London in 1672 for punishment, but by the
time he had arrived the diplomatic winds had
turned again.
Spain had elected to support the Dutch in
the Third Anglo-Dutch War, and was therefore
again an enemy of England.
Morgan walked free, while throngs of commoners
and royalty alike hailed him as a national
hero who had ravaged the hated Spanish.
In the coming decades, rarer and stricter
letters of marque saw less cooperation between
buccaneers of different nations, and eventually
fewer buccaneers altogether.
The reign of the buccaneers ended not in glorious
battle, but in stuffy courtrooms and royal
negotiations.
Disaffected would-be privateers soon left
the West to partake in the so-called Pirate
Round.
Men like Thomas Tew, William Kidd, and Henry
Avery ventured to the coasts of Africa, setting
up base on Madagascar to pillage British East
India and Mughal shipping, and harass Muslim
pilgrimages.
By the time of his death in 1688, the gentrified
Henry Morgan had turned his piratical earnings
into several profitable plantations—raked
and picked by over a hundred miserable slaves.
It was said that Morgan gorged himself on
food and drink in his final years.
Privateers like himself had maintained the
diplomatic veneer of national service; they
attacked and stole within recognized, if often
neglected, parameters set by colonial authorities.
The next generation of pirates would dispense
with such niceties.
Unshackled by diplomacy and unburdened of
the weight of nation, the men of the black
flag answered to no one.
They knelt before no king.
The Caribbean was at their mercy.
A dozen sails rippled above panicked crews.
Hundreds of cannons had been employed to ensure
the safety of this twelve-ship flota.
The Spanish were doing what they had done
for more than a century - heaving gold home
from the New World.
But on this occasion, the figure that captured
the horizon wasn’t a black flag, but a dark
tempest.
Dread overcame the sailors.
It was too late to escape.
Black clouds flooded the skies, and furious
seas took hold of the ships.
Desperate men clung to the masts, which tore
asunder.
Sails flew into the deluge, sailors tumbled
into the void.
One galleon was thrown against the reef; its
hulking shadow sunk into the depths, with
a drowned crew left to rot in the dark of
its cabin.
11 of the 12 vessels suffered the same fate.
In the morning, warm sunlight penetrated the
clouds and shimmered on calm seas.
The storm had claimed over a thousand men.
But Scattered amongst their drifting corpses
were precious metals, fine silks - and seven
million pieces-of-eight-worth of South American
treasure.
This fortune had been slated to sustain the
Empire for the next year - The Spanish at
Havana immediately sent out an expedition
to recover it, but word of the wreck had gotten
out...
“Captain Henry Jennings, sail’d to the
Gulf, and found the Spaniards there upon the
Wreck; the Money before spoken of, was left
on Shore, deposited in a Store-House.
The Rovers came directly upon the Place, bringing
their little Fleet to an Anchor, and, in a
Word, landing 300 Men, they attack’d the
Guard, who immediately ran away; and thus
they seized the Treasure, which they carried
off, making the best of their Way to Jamaica.”
Among the ne’er-do-wells of Port Royal,
Charles Vane had appeared to cut a thoroughly
unremarkable figure - but he had ambition
enough to join his more diplomatic friend,
the former privateer Henry Jennings, who had
managed to cobble together a crew.
The gentlemanly Jennings had intended to stop
the Spanish salvage expedition and steal as
much treasure from the wreckage as he could
- and together that they did.
On their way home from their successful expedition,
Jennings and Vane encountered a Spanish ship.
They raided it too, stole the treasure aboard,
and went on their way.
But selling their loot was complicated.
The world had turned against the pirate.
Gone were the days of unrestrained buccaneering
against the Spanish— this was peacetime,
and London saw to it that its British colonies
disavowed Jennings and the other pirates.
During the War of Spanish Succession, England,
the Dutch Republic, and Portugal had rallied
against France.
Bloodshed and conquest had returned to the
Caribbean, and the privateers roamed free.
But now, the winds had turned yet again and
the debaucherous doors of Port Royal were
closed to stolen goods and maritime outlaws.
If men like Henry Jennings and Charles Vane
were going to become pirates, they would need
friendly ports and a base of operations.
Only a few years removed from war, the Bahamian
island of New Providence, and its city of
Nassau, sat scarred and nearly abandoned.
Green and red-throated parrots warbled above
decaying forts, which hadn’t flown British
colors in years.
Frothy waves lapped against white shores and
leaning palm trees.
Nassau also boasted a natural harbor that
could hold a hundred ships, located near trade
routes and the wreckage of the treasure fleet.
This was the scene the former privateer Benjamin
Hornigold stumbled upon: an Edenic island
bereft of any semblance of governance.
Hornigold quickly assumed control and gave
the pirates exactly what they needed.
Jennings, Vane, and the thousands of other
disaffected sailors were welcomed into the
pirate’s paradise of Nassau.
The pirates clambered ashore with pistols
and swords, and faces freckled with scurvy-spots—-
here, they spent their ill-gotten wealth on
rolls of dice, rounds of rum, and seedy nights
in rundown brothels.
Chests of immaculate gold and silver from
the wreckage made their way into town.
In the throes of treasure fever, the pirates
indulged in lawless excess.
From the fortified port of Nassau, captains
could launch attacks on passing merchant vessels.
“In the Commonwealth of Pyrates, he who
goes the greatest Length of Wickedness, is
looked upon with a kind of Envy amongst them,
as a Person of a more extraordinary Gallantry,
and is thereby entitled to be distinguished
by some Post, and if such a one has but Courage,
he must certainly be a great Man.”
The pirates attacked merchant ships, hauling
in tobacco, rum, cotton, tar, sugar, and slaves
before returning to the safety of Nassau.
Englishmen attacked Englishmen without regard
for common heritage.
Bold brutality became a badge of pride.
For all its anarchical trappings, Nassau came
to be governed, in a sense, by two rival pirate
factions, one under Henry Jennings and the
other under Benjamin Hornigold.
Hornigold’s rising second-in-command, Edward
Teach or Blackbeard, also held sway.
Even so, top-down tyranny had no place in
Nassau.
In a period when monarchies were widespread,
and common sailors languished under draconian
captains for poor wages, this so-called Republic
of Pirates embraced fraternity and proto-egalitarianism
in its undaunting pursuit of wealth.
Half a century before the eloquent democratic
treatises of Paine and Jefferson, the pirate
ship became a primordial site of defiance
toward absolutism and monarchy.
Indeed, the pirates of this era made decisions
collectively, voted out incompetent and unfair
captains, and shared their loot.
Many followed pirate codes that harshly penalized
disloyalty and the cheating of one’s own
crew.
While many still reserved harsh violence for
their victims, pirates like Blackbeard spurned
violence deemed unnecessary, cultivating instead
an aura of fear to force victims into surrendering
without resistance.
The pirate flag, or Jolly Roger, was intended
to do the same.
The red or black flag often flew emblazoned
with icons of death—skulls, bones, and hourglasses.
Pirates used flags strategically; tailing
target vessels and hoisting the feared emblems
of piracy when close enough to make good on
their implicit threat to unleash carnage.
But by 1726, King George I had had enough.
From the opulence of his palace, he made a
dramatic move to annihilate the pirate threat
and conquer Nassau.
His plan would fracture whatever unity these
pitiful enemies of the state professed.
His Majesty had issued a royal pardon.
In this carrot and stick approach, pirates
who surrendered to the proper authorities
in the coming year, would be pardoned and
free to carry on with their lives.
Those who rejected this proposal would, in
turn, receive a price on their head and a
royal promise that they would be hunted down,
arrested, and killed.
When news from New York of the impending pardon
reached the shores of Nassau, hundreds of
pirates rejoiced.
Henry Jennings and Benjamin Hornigold, and
many other former privateers had never intended
to be reviled pirates.
Profit had possessed them, but now they saw
a fortuitous escape to the world of respectable
commerce.
Amidst their euphoria, the pro-pardon pirates
restored the Union Jack atop the fort of Nassau.
But there was a schism.
Hundreds of men refused to return to the mundane
poverty of civility, those who embraced the
life of a ship-borne outlaw and the bloody
quest for fortune and leisure.
These pirates, including Edward England, Christopher
“Billy One-Hand” Condent, and “Calico”
Jack Rackham, now found a leader in the most
diehard, anti-pardon pirate of them all: Charles
Vane.
Vane rallied his supporters and staged an
armed takeover of the fort.
He tore down the Union Jack and raised high
the grinning face of death— the black flag.
For the time being, Nassau would remain the
unapologetic property of pirates, a brazen
island of liberty, chaos, and wealth.
In their defiance of King George, Charles
Vane and his supporters even attempted to
drum up support from the Jacobite cause, which
sought to restore the deposed House of Stuart
upon the British throne.
Although the bid was unsuccessful, tensions
in Nassau were rising.
A pirate council was called in early 1718.
Vane argued that they should fortify the island
and stand against the British.
His old friend Henry Jennings disagreed; he
advocated taking the pardon.
A great clamor and shouting came over the
room, and nothing was decided upon.
The Republic of Pirates felt irrevocably fractured,
and the end appeared close.
The exodus had begun.
Henry Jennings and fifteen of his men sailed
to British Bermuda, and formally received
pardons.
Others fitted their ships for long piratical
journeys elsewhere, to South America or Africa.
Blackbeard, meanwhile, had not been seen for
months.
In February, the HMS Phoenix arrived in Nassau.
Captain Vincent Pearse formally offered the
pirates the king’s pardon.
Benjamin Hornigold and the pro-pardon pirates
happily accepted.
They warned Pearse of the zealous Charles Vane,
who was, at that very moment, outfitting a ship for piracy.
Captain Pearse sailed around the island, and let loose a volley of cannon fire on Vane’s vessel.
He arrested Charles Vane, but, in a show of good faith to the pirates, he released him.
Vane and his crew accepted the king’s pardon with the promise that they would turn away from piracy.
Pearse also informed them that the former buccaneer, Woodes Rogers, had been appointed governor of Nassau and would arrive in the summer to take the island and restore order.
Vane accepted the pardon in the moment, but he hadnt the slightest intention of keeping his word.
Rebellion grew.
Charles Vane hoisted the black flag in defiant theatricality, and left Nassau to exact cruelties on nearby trade routes.
For three weeks, Vane continued like this, hacking and hanging his victims. He captured a dozen merchant ships and crippled trade in the Bahamas.
When he finally sailed back to Nassau, Vane was delighted to find that Pearse had departed to seek repairs for his damaged ship.
A hulking five-vessel fleet with towering
warships approached and laid anchor... Blackbeard was in town.
His 700-strong crew found their land legs
in the taverns and brothels of Nassau.
For a moment, it looked like the glorious,
pre-pardon days of the island had returned.
Blackbeard, however, was not keen on a potential
run-in with Woodes Rogers and the Crown..
In a few days, he and his crew sailed out
again.
Finally, Vane attacked Benjamin Hornigold
and proclaimed himself the governor of New
Providence.
It seemed Charles Vane was the last true pirate
lord in this corner of the world.
Old allies had turned against him - Henry
Jennings had even accepted a privateering
commission to arrest Vane.
But Vane, rich with the spoils of his exploits,
now planned to set sail for Brazil with his
crew— where they might regroup and build
another pirate paradise.
But as they readied their ships, hostile sails
appeared.
Woodes Rogers blocked Vane in the harbor.
This was the final chance to take the pardon
and escape alive.
“[A]ll surrendered to the Pardon, except
Charles Vane and his Crew, which happened
after this Manner...the Harbour to [had] two
Inlets, by Means of a small Island lying at
the Mouth of it; at one of which, both the
Men of War entered, and left the other open,
so that Vane slip’d his Cable, set Fire
to a large Prize they had there, and resolutely
put out, firing at the Man of War as he went
off.”
Woodes Rogers nevertheless became the governor
of New Providence, and he entrusted Benjamin
Hornigold with a dangerous mission to hunt
down Charles Vane.
But Vane had informants and old allies scattered
across the West Indies, and he shrewdly evaded
Rogers and Hornigold at every turn.
As Charles Vane persisted in a bloody tour
of piracy, dozens of superficially reformed
pirates betrayed the pardon, stole ships,
and sailed off to join his cause.
If arrested, they would be tried under maritime
law, and thus afforded no jury.
Pirate trials were little more than a show.
Without the aid of a defense lawyer, the mostly
illiterate sea-thieves would be asked to prove
their innocence to a panel of appointed officials.
The accused would inevitably be found guilty,
hanged on the foreshore, and buried in an
unmarked grave or left to rot in a swinging
cage.
This was the fate the Crown now reserved for
all pirates.
Charles Vane pressed onward.
While many of his old crew— like Edward
England and Christopher Condent— had left
for Africa and Brazil, one powerful pirate
still stalked American waters.
Vane found Blackbeard in the Ocracoke Inlet,
off the coast of North Carolina, and ordered
cannons fired in a salute to his fellow pirate.
As the two crews fraternized and drank for
several nights on the beach, Vane likely attempted
to convince Blackbeard to sail with him, but
Blackbeard sailed off separately, intent on
staging a few last attacks on vulnerable targets
before his own planned retirement from piracy.
But only a month later, in November of 1718,
British Lieutenant Robert Maynard caught up
to Blackbeard and launched a surprise attack.
Blackbeard quickly fired back.
His crew wounded or killed 21 of the British
attackers, and boarded the enemy vessel to
finish the job.
But a dozen British sailors lay hidden in
the hold— they emerged and charged with
Maynard.
Across a deck sleek with blood, in a haze
of musket fire, the giant Blackbeard appeared
and lunged at the rival captain; Maynard locked
swords with Blackbeard.
Swinging furiously, the pair dueled until
at last Maynard stuck his challenger.
The pirate shattered the sword lodged inside
of him.
Blackbeard reached for his pistol, but Maynard
shot him.
The other British sailors overwhelmed the
pirate with gunfire and swords.
“Here was an End of that couragious Brute,
who might have pass’d in the World for a
Heroe, had he been employ’d in a good Cause...The
Lieutenant caused Black-beard’s Head to
be severed from his Body, and hung up at the
Bolt-sprit End, then he sailed to Bath-Town,
to get Relief for his wounded Men.”
It might have seemed prudent for Charles Vane
to avoid a similar fate.
He retreated when a French naval ship fired
on him just a day later, but his crew took
his caution for cowardice.
In accordance with the pirate code, the crew
exercised their right to vote him out.
His shipmate Calico Jack Rackham took the
helm.
With a small gang of loyal supporters, Charles
Vane was sent off in a meager sloop.
Vane continued to attack and rob merchant
vessels, but soon a dark storm descended upon
his ship.
The vessel screeched and teetered over thunderous
swells.
Vane and the crew were thrashed about the
deck, until waves overtook them.
The plunder was lost, and the crew was thrown
overboard...
And yet this wasnt the end.
Among the drifting wreckage that washed up
on the still shores of a desert island were
splintered wood, strips of sail, and the captain
himself, Charles Vane.
The castaway had cheated death.
He crawled ashore through clumped sand and
cursed his wretched lot.
Here, on some unknown stretch of land, Vane
languished.
Days passed under a bleating sun.
He spent his hours gazing out at a desolate
blue-green horizon, seeing not another soul.
Vane
remained brooding on the island for weeks
until, in early 1719, he spotted his saving
opportunity: an English vessel from Jamaica
stopped on the island.
Charles Vane happened to be an old acquaintance
of its commander, Captain Holford.
a retired buccaneer, Holford knew Vane well
enough to bar the conniving pirate from boarding.
Still, some part of Holford took pity on the
castaway.
Rather than arrest Vane outright, Holford
gave his old friend a running start,
“I am now going down the Bay... and shall
return hither, in about a Month; and if I
find you upon the Island when I come back,
I’ll carry you to Jamaica, and hang you.”
Holford sailed off.
And Vane was left to scour the horizon for
a rescuer.
Within a few days, another English ship arrived.
The sailors met the weary castaway and heard
his sympathetic plight.
Vane gave them a false name and joined their
crew.
They began to sail out of the bay.
“One would be apt to think that Vane was
now pretty safe, and likely to escape the
Fate which his Crimes had merited; but here
a cross Accident happen’d that ruin’d
all: Holford, returning from the Bay, was
met with by this Ship; the Captains being
very well acquainted together, Holford was
invited to dine, and as he passed along to
the Cabin, he chanced to cast his Eye down
the Hold, and there saw Charles Vane at work.”
Captain Holford arrested Vane at gunpoint,
and carried the chained pirate back to Jamaica.
There, authorities locked him in a cell.
The antipiracy efforts of the Crown had worked
well.
In short order, the last of the great pirates
would disappear, including those who had fled
eastward.
Pardoned men like Henry Jennings could retire.
The thousands who refused the king’s offer
were hunted down and hanged.
Others lost their lives on the high seas;
some would be dashed against the rocks in
hurricanes.
The great Bartholomew Roberts was shot in
the throat.
And still others, like the brutal Edward Low—who
notoriously forced a man to eat his own broiled
lips— disappeared.
Though likely captured and killed, a wishful Caribbean criminal might imagine missing pirates like Low and Henry Every had made it out alive— that they had cheated the hangman and lived out the rest of their days sipping rum amidst their plunder.
As for Charles Vane, a year in prison culminated
in a stuffy trial, flanked by crimson-clad
colonial guardsmen.
YOn March 29th in the year 1721, Vane was
walked to Gallows Point in the once lawless
Port Royal, and hanged by the neck until he
died.
His executioners placed his lifeless body
in a cage, which teetered for years at the
harbor’s entrance of Gun Cay, such that
the rotting flesh of Charles Vane nourished
the passing crow, and his slumping visage
prophesied the fate of all who sailed under
the black flag.
To Marquis de Lafayette,
“...Let me ask you my Dr. Marquis, in such
an enlightened, in such a liberal age, how
is it possible the great maritime powers of
Europe should submit to pay an annual tribute
to the little piratical States of Barbary?
Would to Heaven we had a navy able to reform
those enemies to mankind, or crush them into
non-existence.”
The Barbary States which had so terrified
Europe under the likes of Dragut, had— over
the centuries— modified the primary means
by which they extracted wealth from the seas.
They now guaranteed safe passage for the feeble
merchant ships that crossed the Mediterranean,
so long as their mother countries submitted
to pay an exorbitant tribute to the Barbary
corsair leaders.
If not, the Barbary corsairs would do what
they had always done; capture the boats and
kill, ransom, or enslave everyone aboard.
The corsairs even forced the fledgling United
States of America to pay the tribute for passage
into the Mediterranean.
By 1797, the Americans had paid, in total,
a fifth of their annual budget to the Barbary
states.
Despite the protests of taxpayers, the United
States had little choice but to pay— they
lacked the naval might to counter the growing
Barbary demands.
Their eventual refusal to pay prompted the
corsairs to capture American vessels and sell
the men aboard in their slave markets; the
monetary loss, buttressed by the image of
enslaved white Americans, proved galvanizing.
President Thomas Jefferson raised an expensive
fleet that sailed out to bombard the Barbary
States.
In the coming years, warships would burn and
whole crews would perish in the fighting.
Sweden and Sicily also took up arms against
their Barbary enemies until, at last, the
Barbary States relented. 1815 saw a three-day
Second Barbary War and a renewed European
commitment to suppress the corsairs after
the Napoleonic Wars.
This was the downfall of these once powerful
pirates, who had roamed the seas since the
Middle Ages.
By that time, the War of 1812 had ended, and
many privateers employed by the British and
Americans found themselves without work.
A simultaneous wave of revolution severed
Spain’s hold on her New World colonies.
The coasts of Latin America and the Caribbean
thus became, once again, fertile ground for
pirates.
But the combined efforts of industrializing
world powers undermined their strength.
President James Monroe spearheaded the efforts
to eradicate pirates.
Meanwhile, state-sanctioned forms of armed
robbery also disappeared from the high seas,
as nations moved away from the practice of
privateering.
These trends were codified in anti-privateering
proclamations and multinational movements,
such that the seas once harassed by the Sea
Peoples, the Victual Brothers, and the buccaneers,
now waxed and waned a little more quietly,
and trade ships followed their routes with
a little more monotony.
A man called Charles Gibbs graced these closing
pages of pirate history without an ounce of
shame.
When arrested and convincted in 1831, the
American pirate admitted to the murder of
400 people and readily told of buried treasure,
“The quantity of money buried in different
parts of the West India Islands is beyond
calculation.
Immense treasures have been secreted there;
a great portion of which will never be found.”
Gibbs was brought to the very same speck of
land that would usher in a new global, urbanized
age.
Under the gaze of Lady Liberty, Ellis Island
would soon receive millions of hopeful immigrants
into the United States.
It was there that Charles Gibbs was hanged.
Piracy had always been complicated; theft,
torture, murder, and enslavement were perpetrated
on the high seas by peoples, states and individuals
possessing varying degrees of legal support.
Men like Francis Drake or Henry Morgan might
have recoiled at the assertion that they were
anything but law-abiding patriots; they fancied
themselves heroes to be lauded, and not outlaws
to be feared.
Charles Gibbs had seemed different.
From the alleged buried treasure to the absurd
number of deaths for which he took credit,
it is thought that much of his post-conviction
confession was fabricated—that perhaps the
ill-fated Gibbs desired, in his final days,
to hoist his legend alongside the pantheon
of pirates who once roamed these waters: outlaws
like Blackbeard, Henry Avery, and Charles
Vane— men for whom piracy was not merely
maritime banditry borne out of desperation,
but a proud culture, a defiant flag raised
brutally against imperial excess— an unjust
enterprise unburdened by the pretense of altruism,
where shameless greed and sadism might lie
alongside nascent republicanism in garish
harmony.
It was at the tail end of the Golden Age,
in July of 1723, when a periodical known as
the Monthly Mercury recounted a bit of news
from the West Indies.
“This Day, 26 of the Pirates taken by his
Majesty Ship the Greyhound, Captain Solgard,
were executed here...Their black Flag, under
which they had committed abundance of Pyracies
and Murders, was affix'd to one Corner of
the Gallows.
It had in it the Portraiture of Death, with
an Hour-Glass in one Hand, and a Dart in the
other, striking into a Heart, and three Drops
of Blood delineated as falling from it.
This Flag they called Old Roger, and us'd
to say, They would live and die under it.”